Try My day,
Joe Rogan podcast by night all day.
Well they a Khabib and Tony are going to fight again though,
right?
Aren't they totally wants to do to the culture.
But here's the thing that makes a bead might not be able to make that weight,
that and,
and you know,
since Kelvin Ms,
wait a couple of times and Dana forced him to find it.
One 85 and I mean,
it makes sense that Dana goes,
dude,
you got to do one 70 at least once or twice,
but miss,
we'll go up in weight to fight him.
Well,
he only missed weight once.
Twice,
twice,
twice.
Tonia huge against,
no,
he's tall,
but he's not,
how tall is he?
He's like,
Tony is like five ten five 11 Tony's bill perfect for the division.
He's torn.
He's got,
he's got a lot of muscle.
Even though he's long.
He's very strong.
He's excellent in the clinch.
I was looking forward to that fight so much.
My heart,
how big it could be.
It could be got a huge frame.
It's a tank.
No,
he doesn't have a nutritionist.
He doesn't talk.
He's not,
you're not being professionals.
He's thick.
Could you hear what Tony Tony to get done when they're like doing media?
Yeah.
And it could be with saying something like why do you get your sunglasses on?
It's like 27 months.
Yeah and he's like good luck or their weight cut breathing cause your cardio's
sucks cause your go songs that's said Tony said to him,
do they have to make it at 55 because what do you do with that fucking bet?
That interim title
fight Floyd.
What the,
we can't just fucking happened the five but don't you think that that's the
fight that has to be made in that division,
right.
That's [inaudible] tone.
If it's,
but if he can't make one 55 can,
he needs to get real and get a fucking digression and we know what happened to
him.
We don't eat Tiramisu the week of,
I know that he did a corn on an bed and Tony even tweet out like for sure when
fucking eat Tiramisu,
he really ate Tiramisu.
That it was on the embedded video.
Whoa.
That's how he smelled it.
He was like,
have fun making weight.
Why are you helping him toughen?
You have to make that fight and could be,
you can do it.
He's just,
he's made it before killing himself.
But we don't know what happened when he had to go to the fucking hospital.
They said he was in massive pain like day Rockhold you're right.
But Luke Rockhold said something.
There was some quote that I had read.
God Damn it.
What did,
see what,
what they said about what,
what did,
uh,
bebes corner list as the official issue that was happening to him.
He was six pounds overweight,
right?
Yes.
When he went to the hospitals.
And that's,
that's huge.
That's so heavy.
You're so heavy when your body's your body shutting down,
like you're six pounds away and your body's shutting down.
You know that come in the week of the fight.
Yeah.
But obviously fucked up with his,
uh,
his discipline if he's eating Tiramisu.
If that's true,
that's even more disappointing.
Maybe you just had a bite,
but either way you don't have a,
and I'm not saying it's the answer.
You don't have a mic dolce or one of these guys who are helping you with your
diet,
right?
Tony's down.
They go up and wait to find them.
You can't do the sense sense for Tony.
It makes sense for Tony mean that wants a fight,
this guy.
But for the division,
it's so weird.
It's like,
well,
what is it sucks the division.
What is this guys?
He puts the entire fights bigger than what the division looks like.
That fight,
that fight needs to happen.
I agree.
I agree with that.
I have is all this other shit's going on.
Mayweather and Garner all this other shit and that's the GSP Bisbing it goes
here it goes medical,
it says a weight.
La,
um,
weight management,
medical issues.
He was treated and it's been discharged.
That doesn't say what the issue is.
This the official us.
See,
see if you could find out.
I feel like I read an article that was interviewing Luke Rockhold.
Rockhold was talking about what happened to [inaudible] Dot Gov did you see Dana
though?
He goes,
if you,
if you would to,
we maybe could have safe drinking.
He gave him a beer.
This isn't beer.
What is it?
It's a real bear
fruit.
Someone gave the Gremlin water after men.
No,
but Dana was saying was panic.
He goes,
oh,
I'm having one.
That's one
damn it.
I knew that the cow.
I got a coffee.
You can't leave.
We guy drinking by himself.
That was the moment the wheels fell off the podcast.
Okay,
here it is.
This is what I read.
Habib wasn't getting any blood to his liver.
Oh,
this is what Luke Rockhold says.
Look,
that is fucking real bad.
So scroll down and let's,
let's see what Luke Rockhold says.
The weight cut wasn't going very well.
Khabib was complaining about a pain in his side and we had to cut short the
weight cut and sure enough,
it gets worse over night and had to go to the hospital.
Unfortunately this is the fight was really fucking four Bababa.
From what I understand,
he wasn't getting any blood to his liver and something went wrong with his
weight cut.
It's very similar to his last fight.
What I understand and just something went wrong.
You never know what these weight cuts,
I guess.
But I think he's ready to go and we can rebook this.
That what is,
he was,
no,
he's the training partner.
He's a AK cause to a hundred pounds heavier training partner.
Yeah.
Well from the same gym.
Yes.
I mean it obviously ain't a hundred pounds.
He's a big deal to walk around.
That could be,
yeah.
Shit.
I Dunno.
I don't wanna miss speak.
I'd assume high seventies yeah.
It looks like it,
right?
Yeah.
And he ain't fat.
No.
They got to make that fight,
man.
That's the fight.
I say that's the Madison ever been when a fight fell through,
like when John and a jail thing.
I really wasn't that math.
There's been other fights.
Uh,
John D C I wasn't that upset.
This one.
I was pissed,
man.
I was really upset.
Tony was on fire,
his camp,
everything was perfect.
It was on such a good fighter.
Okay.